we live in a world increasingly
terrorized by the screen by our phones
by our tablets both televisions and our
computers we can have any experience
that we want but feel nothing we can
have as many friends as we want but have
nobody to shake hands with I want to
take you to a different kind of world
the world of the imagination we're using
this most powerful tool that we have we
can transform both our physical
surroundings but in doing so we can
change forever how we feel and how we
feel about the people that we share the
planet with my company artichoke which I
co-founded 2000 in 2006 was set up to
create moments we all have moments in
our lives and when we're on our
deathbeds we're not going to remember
the daily commute to work on the number
38 bus or our struggle to find a parking
space every day when we go to the shop
we're going to remember those moments
when our kid took their first step or
when we got picked for the football team
or when we fell in love
so artichoke exists to create moving
ephemeral moments that transform the
physical world using the imagination of
the artists to show us what is possible
we create beauty amongst ruins we
re-examine our history we create moments
to which everyone is invited either to
witness or to take part it's all started
from me way back in the 1990s when I was
appointed as festival director in the
tiny British city of Salisbury you'll
probably have heard of it here's the
Salisbury Cathedral and here's the
nearby Stonehenge monument which is
world-famous Salisbury is a city that's
been dominated for hundreds of years by
the church the Conservative Party and
the army it's a place where people
really love to observe the rules so
picture me on my first year in the city
cycling the wrong way down a one-way
street late
I'm always late it's a wonder I've even
turned up today a little old lady on the
sidewalk helpfully shouted at me My dear
you're going the wrong way
charmingly I thought I said yeah I know
I hope you die she's screaming and I
realized that this was a place where I
was in trouble
and yet a year later persuasion
negotiation everything I could deploy
saw me producing the work not a
classical concert in a church or a
poetry reading but the work of a French
street theatre company who were telling
the story of Faust
Mephisto mania on stilts complete with
handheld pyrotechnics the day after same
little old lady stopped me in the street
and said were you responsible for last
night I backed away yes when I heard
about it she said I knew it wasn't for
me
but Helen my dear it was so what has
happened curiosity had triumphed over
suspicion and delight had banished
anxiety so I wondered how one could
transform transfer these ideas to a
larger stage and started on a journey to
do the same kind of thing to London
imagine it's a world city like all our
cities it's dedicated to toil trade and
traffic it's a machine
to get you to work on time and back and
we're all complicit in wanting the
routines to be fixed and for everybody
to be able to know what's going to
happen next and yet what if this amazing
city could be turned into a stage a
platform for something so unimaginable
that would somehow transform people's
lives we do these things often in
Britain I'm sure you do them wherever
you're from
here's Horse Guards Parade and here's
something that we do often it's always
about winning things it's about the
marathon or winning a war or triumphant
cricket team coming home we close the
streets everybody claps but for theater
not possible except a story told by a
French company a saga about a little
girl and a giant elephant the
came to visit for four days and all I
had to do was persuade the public
authorities that shutting the city for
four days was something completely
normal no traffic
just people enjoying themselves coming
out to marvel and witness this
extraordinary artistic endeavor by the
French Theatre Company Royale de looks
it was a seven-year journey with me
saying to a group of men almost always
men sitting in a room it's like a fairy
story with a little girl and this giant
elephant and they come to town for four
days and everybody gets to come and
watch and play and they would go why
would we do this is it for something is
it celebrating a presidential visit is
it the on top cordial between France and
England is it for charity are you trying
to raise money and I'd say none of these
things and they'd say why would we do
this but after four years this magic
trick this extraordinary thing happened
I was sitting in the same meeting I'd
been to for four years saying please
please may I instead of which I didn't
say please I said this thing that we've
been talking about for such a long time
it's happening on these dates and I
really need you to help me this magic
thing happened everybody in the room
somehow decided that somebody else had
said yes
they decided that they were not being
asked to take responsibility
well maybe the bus planning manager was
being asked to take responsibility for
planning that bus diversions and the
council officer was being asked to close
the roads and the Transport for London
people were being asked to sort out the
underground all these people were only
being asked to do the thing that they
could do that would help us nobody was
being asked to take responsibility and I
in my innocence thought well I'll take
responsibility for what turned out to be
a million people on the street it was
our first show it was our first show and
it changed the nature of the
appreciation of culture not in a gallery
not in a theatre not in an opera house
but live and on the streets transforming
public space for the broadest possible
audience people who would never buy a
ticket to see anything so there we were
we'd finished we've continued to produce
work of this kind as you can see the
company's work is astonishing but what's
also astonishing is the fact that
permission was granted and you don't see
any security and this was 9 months after
terrible terrorist bombings that had
ripped London apart so I began to wonder
whether it was possible to do this kind
of stuff in even more complicated
circumstances we turned our attention to
Northern Ireland the north of Ireland
depending on your point of view this is
a map of the of England Scotland Wales
and Ireland the island to the left for
generations it's been a place of
conflict the largely Catholic Republic
in the south and the largely Protestant
loyalist
community who hundreds of years of
conflict British troops on the streets
for over 30 years and now although the
Hat there is a peace process this is
today in this city called Londonderry if
you're a loyalist called Derry if you're
a Catholic but everybody calls it home
and I began to wonder whether there was
a way in which the community tribalism
could be
dressed through art and the imagination
this is what the communities do every
summer
each community this is a bonfire filled
with effigies and insignia from the
people that they hate on the other side
this is the same from the loyalist
community and every summer they burn
them they're right in the center of town
so we turned to here to the Nevada
desert to Burning Man where people also
do bonfires but with a completely
different set of values here you see the
work of David best and his extraordinary
temples which are built during the
Burning Man event and then incinerated
on the Sunday so we invited him and his
community to come and that we recruited
from both sides of the political and
religious divide young people unemployed
people people who would never normally
come across each other or speak to each
other and out of their extraordinary
work rose a temple to rival the two
cathedrals that exist in the town one
Catholic and one Protestant but this was
a temple to no religion for everyone for
no community but for everyone
and we put it in this place where
everyone told me nobody would come it
was too dangerous it was sat between two
communities I just kept saying but it's
got such a great view and again that
same old question why wouldn't we do
this what you see in the picture is the
beginning of four hundred and twenty six
primary school children who were walked
up the hill by their head teacher who
didn't want them to lose this
opportunity and just as happens in the
Nevada desert they're in slightly
different temperatures the people of
this community sixty-five thousand of
them turned out to write their grief
their pain their hope their hopes for
the future their love because in the end
this is only about love they live in a
post-conflict society lots of
post-traumatic stress high suicide and
yet for this brief moment and it would
be ridiculous to assume that it was more
than that somebody like Kevin a Catholic
whose father was shot and when he was
nine upstairs in bed
Kevin came to work as a volunteer and he
was the first person to embrace the
elderly Protestant lady who came through
the door on the day we opened the the
temple to the public it rose up it sat
there for five days and then we chosed
from our little tiny band of
non-sectarian builders who'd given us
their lives for this period of months to
make this extraordinary thing and we
chose from them the people who would
incinerate it and here you see the
moment when witnessed by fifteen
thousand people who turned out on a dark
cold March evening the moment when they
decided to put their emnity behind them
to inhabit this shared space where
everybody had an opportunity to say the
things that had been unsayable to say
out loud you hurt me and my family but I
forgive you
and together they watched as members of
their community let go this thing that
was so beautiful
but was as hard to let go of as those
thoughts and feelings that had gone into
making it
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]